SCP-3930 does not exist…
Thanks for watching.
Now check out “SCP-
The following information is only known to
seven living people.
Even those actively guarding this anomaly
will never know this information.
Every single person who believes they are
aware of the existence of SCP-3930 has the
potential to increase its danger.
SCP-3930 has been given the risk class “Critical”
- the highest possible risk class for an anomaly,
meaning that individuals nearby will invariably
be exposed to acute, life-threatening harm,
and that these effects cannot be mitigated.
You learn about SCP-3930 at your own risk,
with the knowledge that this awareness puts
your life at hazard.
Someday soon, you may be forced to make the
ultimate sacrifice for the good of all life
and matter in the universe.
That is why it is imperative that you know
one essential thing...
SCP-3930 does not exist.
Now with that out of the way, we only have
one question for you...
Can you hear the screaming?
It was when Dr. Vasiliev heard the screaming
that he and his ragtag team of scientists
knew it was already over.
The year was 1971, and Dr. Vasiliev’s team
was stationed at a highly secretive Soviet
research outpost near what would later be
established as the Russian town of Usinsk,
within the Komi Republic.
As far as Dr. Vasiliev was concerned, they
were dead men already.
Well, that’s not entirely accurate.
To be dead is to be… something, and the
men that had once been stationed with them
but were here no longer could not be considered
“something” at all.
Their brush with the immensely powerful and
classified anomaly later known as SCP-3930
had robbed them of their very existence.
Now, Dr. Vasiliev knew that he and the few
remaining men stationed at the base with him
would be next.
The Soviet government had dispatched a detachment
consisting of around a hundred soldiers and
scientists to investigate the anomaly in the
Komi Republic.
As far as they could tell, it appeared to
occupy a one-kilometer squared area within
a forest, but to say that it really “occupied”
anything would be a stretch.
And out of the over hundred men who had been
dispatched, now scarcely thirty remained.
Observation teams had been sent into the anomalous
zone to collect data on what exactly they
were dealing with, but each time, it seemed
as though the researchers were doomed to know
less and less about what they were investigating.
From a distance, the area didn’t even appear
to be anomalous: It looked simply like a continuation
of the forest, complete with the expected
flora, fauna, and even some distant evidence
of human habitation, like an abandoned building.
But without fail, nobody who had ever seen
the building up close had ever returned.
Thanks to SCP-3930, they had simply ceased
to be - because, simply put, when you introduce
something into nothing, the “nothing”
wins.
Dr. Vasiliev had seen too many good men disappear
into oblivion, and soon, it would be his turn,
too.
But first, something horrible would crawl
out of the zone.
Something that shouldn’t exist.
Something that didn’t exist.
Something that never will exist.
And yet here it was.
In science, the observer effect is a dreaded
phenomenon.
All experiments involve the observation of
phenomena to collect data and then prove or
disprove a hypothesis.
But the observer effect describes the frustrating
scenario where the mere act of observing a
phenomenon alters it, reducing the usefulness
of the data.
A common example of this in mundane life is
checking the pressure of your car or bike’s
tires - to do this, you need to let out some
air, thus changing the pressure.
But pressure holds a very different meaning
when you’re working with what might be the
universe’s largest patch of nothing.
Because of their prime directive - namely,
researching the anomaly - Dr. Vasiliev and
his fellow scientists were effectively forced
to observe SCP-3930, and 3930 apparently doesn’t
like that.
The scientists only noticed sounds at first;
barely perceptible little screeches that could
easily be written off as your mind playing
a trick on you.
And, in a sense, it is.
But around SCP-3930, the tricks played by
the mind become a lot more… practical, than
anywhere else.
What started as sounds soon came to take on
a visual form, as more people became aware
of the anomaly and made futile attempts to
observe it from the outside.
These scattered visual and audio forms soon
became nicknamed “Screamers”, for their
horrific, hateful wailing.
Dr. Vasiliev and his team believed that, despite
the extremely hostile nature of the anomalies,
they had no way of ever leaving the anomalous
zone.
That belief was soon proved wrong, and not
long after, only ten researchers remained.
It seemed that the last of Dr. Vasiliev’s
hope died with the lost men but there was
some good news at least.
With only ten left to observe the SCP-3930
anomaly - the Screamers began to disappear
and the anomalous zone became stable once
more.
Ten, it seemed, was the upper limit of observers
that could distantly engage with SCP-3930
before all hell broke loose.
And then the SCP Foundation arrived.
By the time they reached the long-since-defunct
research outpost, Dr. Vasiliev was the only
one left.
The final members of his team had sacrificed
themselves by walking into the void and joining
non-existence.
Vasiliev himself remained for only one purpose:
To tell the Foundation what he knew, what
they needed to know, before bowing out into
SCP-3930 himself - along with however many
of the Foundation personnel needed to go to
keep the number of active observers at a nice,
clean ten.
That is the burden of knowing.
And accepting that burden is to accept that
you may one day need to become unknown in
order to protect your fellow human beings
from the horrors that lay within.
But what is SCP-3930, and what are these so-called
Screamers that lurk within?
We have the answers to these questions.
The only question for you is whether you’re
ready to take on the grave responsibility
of knowing too.
SCP-3930 does not exist.
That isn’t just a cover-up by the O5 Council
- it doesn’t “not exist” in the official
capacity, it is quite literally the world’s
largest patch of nothingness, and anything
that enters it is doomed to become nothing
as well.
It’s a difficult concept to grasp because
fundamentally, all language was built as a
tool to communicate concepts that, on some
level, exist, and SCP-3930 does not qualify.
Close your eyes for a moment - seriously,
do it - and try to imagine nothing.
What do you see?
An infinite space of pure darkness?
A white void, stretching on into infinity?
We’re sorry to inform you that neither of
these counts as being truly nothing.
Though darkness may be the absence of light,
to see that blackness is to still see something.
The darkness even implies the existence of
light.
The same can be said for the white void - for
such a thing to exist, we need both the concept
of the color white and the idea of a void.
These are perhaps the lowest bars for “existence”
imaginable, but SCP-3930 doesn’t meet them.
It is well and truly nothing.
Nothing at all.
And because it is nothing, its containment
procedures are largely just a matter of information
control - if nobody knows about it, the threat
is contained.
If ever someone just happened to wander in,
they would stop existing, so the problem would
take care of itself, as callous as that sounds.
On its own, the anomaly would technically
be harmless, but when mixed with humans, things
become a whole lot more complicated.
You see, unless you have the misfortune to
run into SCP-3930, you will spend your life
without ever having to encounter true nothingness.
Even when you die, the matter that comprises
your body and the energy that comprises your
consciousness will remain, they will just
be transferred into other forms.
Humans have no reason to ever encounter nothingness,
and thus, we have no physiological or psychological
equipment to truly observe and comprehend
nothingness.
When we’re given a true blank, our instinct
is to fill it.
And that right there is the true danger of
SCP-3930, and the very reason we have to deal
with Screamers.
Or, as you may know them, Pattern Screamers.
That’s right - if this whole setup seemed
awfully familiar to you, it’s because SCP-3930
is the absolute global epicenter of Pattern
Screamers, the hateful entities we’ve encountered
before in anomalies like SCP-000.
Nothingness is the natural environment of
Pattern Screamers, but because SCP-3930 is
the only place where true nothingness exists
on our layer of reality, it’s also the only
place where Pattern Screamers are able to
directly interact with humans if they become
powerful and defined enough - often to deadly
and terrifying results.
Pattern Screamers are an incredibly difficult
concept to wrap your head around sometimes,
but allow us to explain.
Close your eyes again, and this time, picture
a clown.
Not a specific clown like Ronald McDonald
or Pennywise, you have to make up your own
clown.
Let’s say he’s got green hair, a big,
blue rubber nose, a wide smile, and polka
dot clown shoes.
The other details are up to you - go as simple
or as complicated as you like, as long as
it’s an entirely new clown you’ve never
seen in real life.
Now hold the image in your head, really focus
on it, you can even use your imagination to
make him dance or walk around.
Fundamentally, this clown does not exist.
Aside from being the product of chemical and
electrical processes in your brain, if this
is indeed an entirely new clown in your mind,
it exists only on the level of thought.
Now imagine if this clown in your mind was
somehow aware of the fact it wasn’t real,
and that it was only the product of your imagination.
Imagine that this clown is infuriated by that
fact - it despises you for bringing it into
being, doomed to be a concept straddling existence
and non-existence.
Imagine this clown wants to hurt you.
It really, really, really wants to hurt you,
with every fiber of its non-existent being.
That right there is a Pattern Screamer.
And the frightening thing about SCP-3930 is
that, if enough people observe it directly,
these Pattern Screamers can become real.
They can crawl out of nothing, and then, they
can show you exactly how they feel about you
bringing them into existence.
And when they’re done, you’ll probably
regret ever existing in the first place.
Think of them as hostile, sentient hallucinations,
capable of reaching maximum power around SCP-3930.
This is because, when humans are given a lack
of stimulus, their minds simply create their
own.
This is why people believe they see the forest
simply continuing into the anomalous zone
- it’s the only way the mind can comprehend
what is going on here.
It’s like the phenomenon of Pareidolia - humans
have a natural tendency to see patterns in
things, even if they were never really there.
It’s from these very patterns that the Pattern
Screamers gain both their form and their name.
They’re monsters that we create, cursed
to live hellish half-existences, and they
hate us for it.
Dr. Vasiliev described SCP-3930 as a kind
of “hateful mirror” that reflects back
the ugliest shards of our own minds, first
broken in the futile quest to comprehend the
true nature of nothingness.
Thousands have likely been lost inside SCP-3930
- if we can even call them “lost”, as
lost implies that something is still out there,
somewhere, even if we never actually find
it.
This cannot be said for the victims of SCP-3930.
They are nowhere and nothing.
They can’t be found again because there
is nothing to find.
The Foundation has used D-Class personnel
to perform manned recon missions into SCP-3930,
feeding information back to the few members
of mission control permitted to be aware of
SCP-3930’s existence without immediate termination.
The D-Classes have ventured well into the
heart of nothingness, even reaching and entering
the building that can be seen in the distance.
There, they’ve found messes of haunting
inconsistencies.
The place looks like it’s been abandoned
for decades, but also has evidence of recent
habitation.
Doors and windows move.
Curtains and hallways go on forever.
They feel a sound in their ears that’s similar
to the screech of TV static.
No, not a screech, really more of a scream.
It’s always in that moment that the realization
hits them: They don’t exist, not anymore,
and they haven’t for a little while now.
They’re just a few scattered memories of
the Foundation researcher talking to them,
reflected back by SCP-3930’s hateful mirror.
And moments later, they’re gone, almost
like they were never here at all.
So if ever anyone asks you, “What is SCP-3930?”
You know that there’s only ever one answer.
SCP-3930 does not exist.
Now check out “The Lost SCP - SCP-000”
and “SCP-096 - Look at a Picture of Shy
Guy in Space?
The Shy Guy Questions and Theories” to delve
into more of the SCP Foundation’s deepest,
darkest secrets!